2 times this equation, Okay.
This is it.
The second lecture
in linear algebra,
and I've put below my
main topics for today.
I put right there a
system of equations
that's going to be our
example to work with.
But what are we
going to do with it?
We're going to solve it.
And the method of solution
will not be determinants.
Determinants are something
that will come later.
The method we'll use
is called elimination.
And it's the way every software
package solves equations.
And elimination, well, if it
succeeds, it gets the answer.
And normally it does succeed.
If the matrix A that's
coming into that system
is a good matrix, and
I think this one is,
then elimination will work.
We'll get the answer
in an efficient way.
But why don't we, as long
as we're sort of seeing how
elimination works -- it's
always good to ask how could it
fail?
So at the same
time, we'll see how
elimination decides whether
the matrix is a good one
or has problems.
Then to complete
the answer, there's
an obvious step of
back substitution.
In fact, the idea
of elimination is --
you would have
thought of it, right?
I mean Gauss thought
of it before we did,
but only because he
was born earlier.
It's a natural idea...
and died earlier, too.
Okay, and you've seen the idea.
But now, the part that I want
to show you is elimination
expressed in matrix language,
because the whole course --
all the key ideas get expressed
as matrix operations, not as
words.
And one of the operations,
of course, that we'll meet
is how do we multiply
matrices and why?
Okay, so there's a
system of equations.
Three equations
and three unknowns.
And there's the matrix, the
three by three matrix --
so this is the system Ax = b.
This is our system
to solve, Ax equal --
and the right-hand side
is that vector 2, 12, 2.
Okay.
Now, when I describe
elimination --
it gets to be a pain to
keep writing the equal signs
and the pluses and so on.
It's that matrix
that totally matters.
Everything is in that matrix.
But behind it is
those equations.
So what does elimination do?
What's the first
step of elimination?
We accept the first
equation, it's okay.
I'm going to multiply that
equation by the right number,
the right multiplier and
I'm going to subtract it
from the second equation.
With what purpose?
So that will decide what
the multiplier should be.
Our purpose is to knock out
the x part of equation two.
So our purpose is
to eliminate x.
So what do I multiply --
and again, I'll do
it with this matrix,
because I can do it short.
What's the multiplier here?
What do I multiply --
equation one and subtract.
Notice I'm saying
that word subtract.
I'd like to stick
to that convention.
I'll do a subtraction.
First of all this is the key
number that I'm starting with.
And that's called the pivot.
I'll put a box around it
and write its name down.
That's the first pivot.
The first pivot.
Okay.
So I'm going to use --
that's sort of like the key
number in that equation.
And now what's the multiplier?
So I'm going to --
my first row won't change,
that's the pivot row.
But I'm going to use it --
and now, finally, let me ask
you what the multiplier is.
Yes?
3 times that first equation
will knock out that 3.
Okay.
So what will it leave?
So the multiplier is 3.
3 times that will make that 0.
That was our purpose.
3 2s away from the 8 will leave
a 2 and three 1s away from 1
will leave a minus 2.
And this guy didn't change.
Now the next step -- this is
forward elimination and that
Okay. step's completed.
Oh, well, you could say wait
a minute, what about the right
hand side?
Shall I carry -- the right-hand
side gets carried along.
Actually MatLab finishes up
with the left side before --
and then just goes back
to do the right side.
Maybe I'll be MatLab for
a moment and do that.
Okay.
I'm leaving a room for a column
of b, the right-hand side.
But I'll fill it in later.
Okay.
Now the next step of
elimination is what?
Well, strictly speaking...
this position that I cleaned
up was like the 2, 1 position,
row 2, column 1.
So I got a 0 in
the 2, 1 position.
I'll use 2,1 as the
index of that step.
The next step should
be to finish the column
and get a 0 in that position.
So the next step is really
the 3,1 step, row three,
column one.
But of course, I already have 0.
Okay.
So the multiplier is 0.
I take 0 of this equation away
from this one and I'm all set.
So I won't repeat that, but
there was a step there which,
MatLab would have to look --
it would look at this number
and, do that step, unless you
told it in advance that it was
0.
Okay.
Now what?
Now we can see the second
pivot, which is what?
The second pivot --
see, we've eliminated --
x is now gone from
this equation, right?
We're down to two
equations in y and z.
And so now I just do it again.
Like, everything's very cursive
at this -- this is like --
such a basic algorithm
and you've seen it,
but carry me through
one last step.
So this is still
the first pivot.
Now the second pivot is this
guy, who has appeared there.
And what's the multiplier, the
appropriate multiplier now?
And what's my purpose?
Is it to wipe out the
3, 2 position, right?
This was the 2, 1 step.
And now I'm going to
take the 3, 2 step.
So this all stays the
same, 1 2 1, 0 2 -1
and the pivots are there.
Now I'm using this pivot,
so what's the multiplier?
this row, gets subtracted from
this row and makes that a 0.
So it's 0, 0 and is it a 5?
Yeah, I guess it's
a 5, is that right?
Because I have a
one there and I'm
subtracting twice of twice
this, so I think it's a 5 there.
There's the third pivot.
So let me put a box
around all three pivots.
Is there a -- oh, did I
just invent a negative one?
I'm sorry that the tape
can't, correct that
as easily as I can.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
You get an A in the course now.
Is that correct?
Is it correct now?
Okay.
So the three pivots are there --
I know right away a
lot about this matrix.
This elimination step from A --
this matrix I'm going to call
U. U for upper triangular.
So the whole purpose
of elimination
was to get from A to U.
And, literally, that's the
most common calculation
in scientific computing.
And people think of how
could I do that faster?
Because it's a
major, major thing.
But we're doing it the
straightforward way.
We found three pivots, and by
the way, I didn't say this,
pivots can't be 0.
I don't accept 0 as a pivot.
And I didn't get 0.
So this matrix is great.
It gave me three
pivots, I didn't
have to do anything special,
I just followed the rules and,
and the pivots are 1, 2 and 5.
By the way, just because I
always anticipate stuff from
a later day, if I wanted to know
the determinant of this matrix
-- which I never
do want to know,
but I would just
multiply the pivots.
The determinant is 10.
So even things like the
determinant are here.
Okay.
Now -- oh, let me talk
about failure for a moment,
and then --
and then come back to success.
How could this have failed?
How could -- by fail, I mean
to come up with three pivots.
I mean, there are
a couple of points.
I would have already
been in trouble
if this very first
number here was 0.
If it was a 0 there --
suppose that had been a 0,
there were no Xs in that
equation -- first equation.
Does that mean I can't
solve the problem?
Does that mean I quit?
No.
What do I do?
I switch rows.
I exchange rows.
So in case of a 0, I
will not say 0 pivot.
I will never be heard to
utter those words, 0 pivot.
But if there's a 0 in
the pivot position,
maybe I can say
that, I would try
to exchange for a lower equation
and get a proper pivot up
there.
Okay.
Now, for example, this
second pivot came out two.
Could it have come out 0?
What -- actually, if I
change that 8 a little bit,
I would have got
a little trouble.
What should I change that 8
to so that I run into trouble?
A 6.
If that had been a 6, then
this would have been 0
and I couldn't have
used that as the pivot.
But I could have
exchanged again.
In this case.
In this case, because when
can I get out of trouble?
I can get out of
trouble if there's
a non-0 below this
troublesome 0.
And there is here.
So I would be okay in this case.
If this was a 6, I
would survive by a row
exchange.
Now -- of course, it might have
happened that I couldn't do
the row, that -- that
there was 0s below it,
but here there wasn't.
Now, I could also have got in
trouble if this number 1 was
a little different.
See, that 1 became a
5, I guess, by the end.
So can you see what
number there would
have got me trouble that I
really couldn't get out of?
Trouble that I
couldn't get out of
would mean if 0 is
in the pivot position
and I've got no
place to exchange.
So there must be some number
which if I had had here
it would have meant failure.
Negative 4, good.
If it was a negative 4 here --
if it happened to be a negative
4, I'll temporarily
put it up here.
If this had been a
negative 4 z, then I
would have gone
through the same steps.
This would have been a minus
4, it still would have been a
minus 4.
But at the last minute
it would have become 0.
And there wouldn't have
been a third pivot.
The matrix would have
not been invertible.
Well, of course, the inverse of
a matrix is coming next week,
but, you've heard these words
before.
So, that's how we
identify failure.
There's temporary failure when
we can do a row exchange --
and get out of it, or there's
complete failure when we get
a 0 and --
and there's nothing
below that we can use.
Okay.
Let's stay with --
back to success now.
In fact, I guess the next
topic is back substitution.
So what's back substitution?
Well, now I'd better bring
the right-hand side in.
So what would MatLab do
and what should we do?
Let me bring in the right-hand
side as an extra column.
So there comes B.
So it's 2, 12, I would call
this the augmented matrix.
"Augment" means you've
tacked something on.
I've tacked on
this extra column.
Because, when I'm
working with equations,
I do the same thing
to both sides.
So, at this step, I subtracted 2
of the first equation away from
the second equation so
that this augmented --
I even brought some colored
chalk, but I don't know if it
shows up.
So this is like the augmented --
no!
Damn, circled the wrong thing.
Okay.
Here is b.
Okay, that's the extra column.
Okay.
So what happened to
that extra column,
the right-hand side
of the equations,
when I did the first step?
So that was 3 of this away
from this, so it took --
the 2 stayed the same, but
three 2s got taken away from 12,
leaving 6, and that
2 stayed the same.
So this is how it's
looking halfway along.
And let me just
carry to the end.
The 2 and the 6 stay
the same, but --
what do I have here?
Oh, gosh.
Help me out, now.
What -- so now I'm --
This is still like
forward elimination.
I got to this point,
which I think is right,
and now what did
I do at this step?
I multiplied that pivot by 2
or that whole equation by 2
and subtracted from
that, so I think
I take two 6s, which
is 12, away from the 2.
Do you think minus 10 is
my final right-hand side --
the right-hand side that
goes with U, and let me
call that once and
forever the vector c.
So c is what happens to b,
and U is what happens to A.
Okay.
There you've seen
elimination clean.
Okay.
Oh, what's back substitution?
So what are my final
equations, then?
Can I copy these equations?
x+2y+z=2 is still there and
2y-2z=6 is there, and 5z=-10.
Okay.
Those are the equations
that these numbers
are telling me about.
Those are the
equations U x equals c.
Okay, how do I solve them?
What one do I solve for first?
z.
I see immediately that the
correct value of z is negative
And what do I do next?
I go back upwards.
I now know z here.
So, if z is negative 2,
that's 4 there, is that right?
And so 2 y plus a 4
is 6, maybe y is 1.
Going -- this is
back substitution.
We're doing it on the
fly because it's so easy.
And then x is --
so x -- 2y is 2 minus
2, maybe x is 2?
So you see what back
substitution is.
It's the simple step solving
the equations in reverse order
because the system
is triangular.
Okay.
Good.
So that's elimination
and back substitution,
and I kept the
right-hand side along.
Okay, now what do I --
that, like, is
first piece of the
lecture.
What's the second piece?
Matrices are going to get in.
So I wrote stuff with x, y-s
and z-s in there, then I really,
got the right shorthand, just
writing the matrix entries,
and now I want to
write the operations
that I did in matrices, right?
I've carried the
matrices along, but I
haven't said the operation
those elimination steps,
I now want to
express as matrices.
Okay.
Here they come.
So now this is
elimination matrices.
Okay.
Let me take that first step,
which took me from 1 2 1 3 8 1
0 4 1.
I want to operate on that --
I want to do
elimination on that.
Okay.
Okay, now I'm
remembering a point
I want to single out as
especially important.
Let me move the
board up for that.
Because when we do matrix
operations, we've got to, like,
be able to see the big picture.
Okay.
Last time, I spoke about
the big picture of --
when I multiply a matrix
by a right-hand side.
If I have some matrix there
and I multiply it by 3 4 5,
let's say --
so here's a matrix --
what did I say -- well,
I guess I only said it
on the videotape, but -- do
you remember how I look at that
matrix multiplication?
The result of multiplying
a matrix by some vector
is a combination of the
columns of the matrix.
It's 3 times the first column.
It's 3 times column one plus 4
times column two plus 5 times
column three.
Okay.
I'm going to come back
to that multiple times.
What I wanted to do now was to
emphasize the parallel thing
with rows.
Why?
Because all our operations
here for this two weeks
of the course are
row operations.
So this isn't what I
need for row operations.
Let me do a row operation.
Suppose I have my matrix
again and suppose I multiply
on the left by some
-- let's say 1 2 7.
Again, I'm just, like,
saying what the result is.
And then we'll say how
matrix multiplication works
and we'll see that it's true.
Okay.
But maybe already I'm making --
I'm sort of bringing up -- the
central idea of linear algebra
is how these matrices work by
rows as well as by columns.
Okay.
How does it work by rows?
What -- so that's a row vector.
I could say that's a one
by three matrix, a row
vector multiplying a
three by three matrix.
What's the output?
What's the product of
a row times a matrix?
And -- okay, it's a row.
A row -- a column --
I'm sorry.
A matrix times a
column is a column.
So matrix times a -- yeah.
Matrix times a
column is a column.
And we know what column it is.
Over here, I'm doing
a row times a matrix.
And what's the answer?
It's one of that first
row, so it's 1 times --
1 times row one, plus 2 times
row two plus 7 times row three.
When -- as we do
matrix multiplication,
keep your eye on what it's
doing with whole vectors.
And what it's doing -- what
it's doing in this case is
it's combining the rows.
And we have a combination, a
linear combination of the rows.
Okay, I want to use that.
Okay, so my question is what's
the matrix that does this first
step, that takes -- subtracts
3 of equation one from equation
two?
That's what I want to do.
So this is going to
be a matrix that's
going to subtract 3 times
row one from row two,
and leaves the other rows the
same.
Just in -- I mean, the
answer is going to be that.
So whatever matrix this is --
and you're going to, like,
tell me what matrix will do it,
it's the matrix that leaves
the first row unchanged,
leaves the last row unchanged,
but takes 3 of these
away from this so it puts a 0
there, a 2 there and a minus 2.
Good.
What matrix will do it?
It's these.
It should be a
pretty simple matrix,
because we're doing
a very simple step.
We're just doing this
step that changes row two.
So actually, row
one is not changing.
So tell me how the
matrix should begin.
One -- the first row of
the matrix will be 1 0 0,
because that's just the right
thing that takes one of that
row and none of the other
rows, and that's what we want.
What's the last
row of the matrix?
0 0 1, because that takes
one of the third row
and none of the other
rows, that's great.
Okay.
Now, suppose I didn't want
to do anything at all.
Suppose my row -- well, I guess
maybe I had a case here when I
already had a 0 and,
didn't have to do anything.
What matrix does nothing, like,
just leaves you where you were?
If I put in --
if I put in 0 1 0, that
would be -- that would be --
that's the matrix -- what's
the name of that matrix?
The identity matrix, right.
So it does absolutely nothing.
It just multiplies everything
and leaves it where it is.
It's like a one, like the
number one, for matrices.
But that's not what we want,
because we want to change this
row to --
so what's the correct --
what should I put in
here now to do it right?
I want to get -- what do I want?
What I -- I'm after --
I want 3 of row one
to get subtracted
off.
So what's the right matrix,
finish that matrix for me.
Negative 3 goes here?
And what goes here?
That 1.
The 0.
That's the good matrix.
That's the matrix
that takes minus 3
of row one plus the row two
and gives the new row 2.
Should we just, like,
check some particular
entry?
How do I check a
particular entry
of a matrix in matrix
multiplication?
Like, suppose I wanted to check
the entry here that's in row
two, column three.
So where does the entry in row
two, column three come from?
I would look at
row two of this guy
and column three of this
one to get that number.
That number comes from the
second row and the third column
and I just take this
dot product minus 3 --
I'm multiplying -- minus 3
plus 1 and 0 gives the minus 2.
Yeah.
It works.
So we got various ways
to multiply matrices now.
We're sort of,
like -- informally.
We've got by columns,
we've got -- well,
we will have by columns,
by rows, by each entry at a
time.
But it's good to see that
matrix multiplication when one
of the matrices is so simple.
So this guy is our
elementary matrix.
Let's call it E for
elementary or elimination.
And let me put the indexes 2 1,
because it's the matrix that we
needed to fix the 2 1 position.
It's the matrix that we
needed to get this 2 1
position to be Okay.
Good enough.
So what do I do next?
I need another matrix, right?
I need to --
there's another step here.
And I want to express
the whole elimination
process in matrix language.
So tell me what -- so next
step, step two, which was what?
Subtract -- what was -- what
was the actual step that we did?
I think I subtracted
-- do you remember?
I had a 2 in the pivot
and a 4 below it,
so I subtracted two times --
times row two from row three.
From row three.
Tell me the matrix
that will do that.
And tell me its name.
Okay, it's going to be E,
for elementary or elimination
matrix and what's the index
number that I used to tell me
what E --
3, 2, right?
Because it's fixing
this 3 2 position.
And what's the matrix, now?
Okay, you remember -- so E 3 2
is supposed to multiply my guy
that I have and it's supposed
to produce the right result,
which was -- it leaves -- it's
supposed to leave the first
row, it's supposed to leave the
second row and it's supposed
to straighten out that
third row to this.
And what's the matrix
that does that?
1 0 0, right?
Because we don't change the
first row and the next row
we don't change either,
and the last row
is the one we do change.
And what do I do?
Let's see, I
subtract two times --
so what's this row?
What's this here?
0, right, because the
first row's not involved.
It's just in the 3 2
position, isn't it?
This the key number is this
minus the multiplier that goes
-- sitting there in
that 3 2 position.
Is it a minus 2 to subtract 2
and then this is a 1 so that --
the overall effect is to take
minus 2 of this row plus 1 of
that.
Okay.
So, I've now given you the
pieces, the elimination
matrices, the elementary
matrices that take each step.
So now what?
Now the next point
in the lecture
is to put those steps together
into a matrix that does it all
and see how it all happens.
So now I'm going to
express the whole --
everything we did today so
far on A was to start with A,
we multiplied it by E 2 1,
that was the first step --
and then we multiplied that
result by E 3 2 and that led us
to this thing and
what was that matrix?
U.
You see why I like
matrix notation,
because there in,
like, little space --
a few bits when its compressed
on the web -- is everything --
is this whole lecture.
Okay.
Now there -- there are
important facts about matrix
multiplication.
And we're close to maybe
the most important.
And that is this.
Suppose I ask you this question.
Suppose I start with
a matrix A and I
want to end with
a matrix U and I
want to say what matrix
does the whole job?
What matrix takes me from A to
U, using the letters I've got?
And the answer is simple.
I'm not asking this as --
but it's highly important.
How would I create
the matrix that
does the whole job
at once, that does
all of elimination in one shot?
It would be --
I would just put
these together, right?
In other words, this is the
thing I'm struggling to say.
I can move those parentheses.
If I keep the
matrices in order --
I can't mess around with
the order of the matrices,
but I can change the order
that I do the multiplications.
I can multiply
these two first --
in other words, you see what
those parentheses are doing?
It's saying -- multiply the
Es first and that gives you
the matrix that does
everything at once.
Okay.
So this fact, that this is
automatically the same as this
--
for every matrix multiplication,
which I'm conscious of still
not telling you in
every detail, but, like,
you're seeing how it works --
and this is highly important --
and maybe tell me the long
word that describes this law
for matrices, that you
can move the parentheses?
It's called the associative law.
I think you can now forget that.
But don't forget the law.
I mean, like, forget
the word associative.
I don't know.
But don't forget the law.
Because actually, we'll see so
many steps in linear algebra,
so many proofs,
even, of main fact
come from just moving
the parentheses.
And it's not that easy to
prove that this is correct,
you have to go into the
gory details of matrix
multiplication, do
it both ways and see
that you come out the same.
Maybe I'll leave the
author to do that.
Okay.
So there we go.
So there's a single matrix,
I could call it E --
while we're talking about these
matrices, tell me one other --
there's another type
of elementary matrix,
and we already said
why we might need it.
We didn't need it in this case.
But it's the matrix
that exchanges two rows.
It's called a
permutation matrix.
Can you just, like, tell me what
that would So I'm just -- like,
this is a slight digression
and be? we'll -- yes,
so let me get some -- let me
figure out where I'm going
to put a permutation matrix.
You'll see I'm always
squeezing stuff in.
So permutation.
Or, in fact this one you'll,
like, exchange rows --
shall I exchange rows one and
two, just to make life easy?
So if I had my matrix -- no, let
-- let me just do two by two.
|a b; c d|.
Suppose I want to find
the matrix that exchanges
those rows.
What is it?
So the matrix that
exchanges those rows --
the row I want is
c d and it's there.
So I better take one of it.
And the row I want here is up
top, so I'll take one of that.
So actually, I'm just --
the easy way -- this is my
matrix that I'll call P,
for permutation.
It's the matrix -- actually, the
easy way to find it is just do
the thing to the
identity matrix.
Exchange the rows of
the identity matrix
and then that's the matrix that
will do row exchanges for you.
Suppose I wanted to
exchange columns instead.
Columns have hardly got
into today's lecture,
but they certainly are
going to be around.
How could I -- if I started
with this matrix |a b; c d|
then I wouldn't --
I'm not even going
to write this down,
I'm just going to ask you,
because in elimination, we're
doing rows.
But suppose we
wanted to exchange
the columns of a matrix.
How would I do that?
What matrix multiplication
would do that job?
Actually, why not?
I'll write it down.
So this is --
I'll write it under here
and then hide it again.
Okay.
Suppose I had my
matrix |a b; c d|
and I want to get to a c
over here and b d here.
What matrix does that job?
Can I multiply -- can I cook up
some matrix that produces that
answer?
You can see from where I
put my hand I was really
asking can I put a matrix
here on the left that
will exchange columns?
And the answer is no.
I'm just bringing
out again this point
that when I multiply on the
left, I'm doing row operations.
So if I want to do
a column operation,
where do I put that
permutation matrix?
On the right.
If I put it here, where I just
barely left room for it --
so I'll exchange the two
columns of the identity.
Then it comes out
right, because now I'm
multiplying a column at a time.
This is the first column
and says take one --
take none of that column,
one of this one and then you
got it.
Over here, take one
of this one, none
of this one and you've got a c.
So, in short, to do
column operations,
the matrix multiplies
on the right.
To do row operations, it
multiplies on the left.
Okay, okay, and it's row
operations that we're really
doing.
Okay.
And of course, I
mentioned in passing,
but I better say it very
clearly that you can't exchange
the orders of matrices.
And that's just the point
I was making again here.
A times B is not the
same as B times A.
You have to keep these matrices
in their Gauss given order
here, right?
But you can move
the parentheses,
so that, in other words,
the commutative law, which
would allow you to take it
in the other order is false.
So we have to keep
it in that order.
Okay.
So what next?
I could do this multiplication.
I could do E 32.
So let me come back
to see what that was.
Here was E 2 1.
And here is E 3 2.
And if I multiply those
two matrices together --
E 3 2 and then E 2 1,
I'll get a single matrix
that does elimination.
I don't want to do it that --
if I do that multiplication --
there -- there's a
better way to do this.
And so in this last few
minutes of today's lecture,
can I anticipate
that better way?
The better way is to think
not how do I get from A to U,
but how do I get
from U back to A?
So reversing steps
is going to come in.
Inverse -- I'll use
the word inverse here.
Okay.
So let me make the first step
at what's the inverse matrix?
All the matrices you've seen
on this board have inverses.
I didn't write any
bad matrices down.
We spoke about possible
failure, and for a moment,
we put in a matrix
that would fail.
But right now, all
these matrices are good,
they're all invertible.
And let's take the
inverse -- well,
let me say first what does
the inverse mean and find it?
Okay.
So we're getting a little
leg up on inverses.
Okay, so this is the
final moments of today.
Sorry, he's still there.
Okay.
Inverses.
Okay, and I'm just going
to take one example
and then we're done.
The example I'll take will
be that E. So my matrix
is 1 0 0 minus 3 1 0 0 0 1.
And I want to find the
matrix that undoes that step.
So what was that step?
The step was subtract 3
times row one from row two.
So what matrix will get me back?
What matrix will bring back --
you know, if I started with a 2
12 2 and I changed it to a 2 6
2 because of this guy, I want
to get back to the 2 12 I want
to find the matrix which --
which undoes elimination,
the matrix which multiplies
this to give the identity.
And you can tell me what I
should do in words first,
and then we'll write down
the matrix that does it.
If this step subtracted
3 times row 1 from row 2,
what's the inverse step?
I add 3 times row one
to row two, right?
I add it back.
The -- what I subtracted
away, I add back.
So the inverse matrix
in this case is --
I now want to add 3
times row one to row two,
so I won't change row one,
I won't change row three
and I'll add 3 times
row one to row two.
That's a case where
the inverse is clear.
It's clear in words what to
do, because what this did
was simple to express.
It just changed row two by
subtracting 3 of row one.
So to invert it, I go that way.
And if you -- if we
do that calculation,
3 times this row plus
1 times this row,
comes out the right
row of the identity.
Okay, so inverses are an --
so if this matrix was E and this
matrix is I for identity, then
what's the notation
for this guy?
E to the minus one.
E inverse.
Okay.
Let's stop there for today.
That's a little jump on
what's coming on Monday.
So, see you Monday.